so we know that the the decision in the
Darren Wilson case in Ferguson is going
to come down it could come down today it
could come down sometime they're saying
before december first whether he will be
indicted for killing Michael Brown and
already everyone's saying that there is
going to be violent they've already
declared a state of emergency in
Ferguson it's a big mess we've got a
video it's a little more worried about
the violent pass and with new
intelligence coming in the FBI has sent
a bulletin to police across the country
it warns that violent individuals will
likely try to exploit peaceful protests
and attack law enforcement in Ferguson
and possibly nationwide according to the
bulletin suspects could be armed with
knives and guns and tactical gear like
tear gas masks and bulletproof vests the
warning site specific recent
intelligence that's causing concern
including threatening messages okay so
basically we're sort of pre-empting the
violence by saying that there is going
to be violence I'm pretty convinced that
regardless of whether he's indicted or
not there is going to be violent
violence either way I mean clearly if he
isn't indicted I'm pretty sure there's
going to be loud and I have a feeling
that even if he is when you have this
many people together and so many people
with different motives and everything
else I think there's gonna be bouncing
either way I think you're absolutely
right i mean and i'm not i'm not
comparing these two things but I guess I
am because the first thing I think of us
look how crazy people go in their team
wins exactly nope but really really you
know people just express themselves very
physically sometimes whether they're
happy or they're sad but and I I agree
you have to prepare for these things you
have to make sure people are safe and
protected however you don't use that as
an excuse to show up with gigantic
tankers and bazookas and get ready to
you know kill everyone in the crowd yeah
so has the precedent already been set
here that they'll be violence because of
what happened in the over militarization
of the police and everything else like
have we already set that this is emotion
already I grew up in Los Angeles and we
do riots you know and I don't have any
since I've been here just the right okay
we also we also do you know we do riots
when the lakers win and this
that's a great point yeah um but uh the
we also do earthquakes and earthquakes
happen you just don't know when the big
ones gonna be so I'm pretty sure
something's going to happen regardless I
can't I can't I don't know the riots why
riots would happen if he is indicted
well only because so many people are
gonna be out there the police are still
gonna be there and there's just this
undercurrent right uh like it's just
like this like amorphous thing and
someone just set off a firecracker went
whatever reason one person who does not
when the reason any of this is happening
is because the police and the the
general public don't really communicate
well it's gonna really suck when it when
that under current is is translating
into like this big national attention
moment yeah I don't know it's it's tough
hopefully it won't be a big eruption of
violence it doesn't I mean it sounds
like it should help to have tanks there
to stop violence but it but but it's not
going to I understand the idea to bring
tanks that's just really not gonna help
at all go ahead what doesn't it seem you
know just the way they put it like there
could be a this could a and earth there
could be guns and knives there there
could be a lot of things but doesn't it
sound like they're setting themselves up
to excuse their behavior it's to excuse
their behavior or just like I sort of
feel like the media kind of wants it too
when we talk about this with Ebola and
everything else where there's just
always this lead in that gets everyone
juice like the protesters now know how
the FBI's talking about us already like
and also doesn't it help the protesters
argument if there is violence
unfortunately you know I mean yeah it
sure then they go well look there's more
violence so we're even more screwed
everybody wins in the worst possible way
if something horrible happened yeah so
what are the police supposed to do
because obviously those images were
awful and tanks in the sniper with the
guy right in front of him and all that
stuff it's terrible we don't want that
on our streets obviously but if there
are riots what are the police and the
National Guard actually what's within
their right to do if they're looting
stores and all that stuff there's
there's certain you know they instead of
putting bullets in their guns they put
like little beanbag pellets so there
there's they have riot gear yeah I
assume you use that don't kill anybody
the
problem is yeah if if there don't don't
erupt into the violent shooting sprees
justice get it to stop right isn't that
someone could shoot them with a live
bullet that's what I mean about this
like endless thing that I mean listen
this gets to the heart of like why maybe
it happened in the first place like the
the the idea of being a police officer
is frightening to me still like know if
if the situation was such that that the
police officer was not provoked at all
like that's not okay but I can't imagine
what it's like to be a police officer
the same way I can't imagine what it's
like to be profiled on the street you
know other than being like really
non-threatening which is what people you
know determine about me because they
just don't work out I you're pretty
threatening thing I've seen you late at
night wandering the streets of LA office
early thank you thank you so much um
really though is there anything so we
don't know literally this could the
decision could come down while we're
sitting here right the second door could
come down next week whatever it is but
since we have this lead time where we
know that this decisions coming is there
anything that anyone can do to calm
tensions because it seems like
everything we're doing is just
ratcheting tension skis they're like
we're we have time now is there a
nothing we can do I don't want to
speculate here but you know today cin
honestly I think just little chocolate
treats if you give people a bunch of
bunch of candy I mean it does a lot I
mean honestly i don't i don't know the
honest answer halloween a sequel yeah
exactly another halloween no costumes I
think there's I'm not a historian but
i'm sure there's been riots in the past
that haven't erupted in a nationwide
outrage right things have been contained
things have ended relatively peacefully
relatively quickly without major
bloodshed and major Horror so maybe we
need to go back and look at the tape of
things that haven't ended so horrific
Lee that this is going to be what we're
talking about in teaching in schools for
the next couple decades yeah well on
that note I hope that I am completely
wrong on this one I fear that i'm not
but i hope that i am what do you think a
comment right down below